Joining me today as a biologist,
a former professor at evergreen state
who is now a professor in exile,
Bret Weinstein.
Welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me back on.
Professor in exile a friend.
That's what it says on your twitter bio,
which means it's your most defining
characteristic right now.
That has become the tenor of my life.
All right,
so I went into the Rubin report
archives.
They're very much like the Jedi
I went into the Rubin Report Archives
this morning that you were on this show
originally on May 30th,
2017.
So that's about a year and a half ago.
It was just as the Evergreen Brouhaha
was beginning you,
you still were employed at the time,
uh,
which probably seems like a lifetime
ago.
Um,
so I think first maybe we should just
play a little catch up from that and I
just to be clear,
you had been on the show one since then.
You were on with your brother Eric,
and we did a little bit about evergreen
in your life,
but I saw,
I thought first let's do to catch up on
what happened,
where you're at,
where you're going,
and then we're going to do sort of new
territory and we're going to cover a lot
of biology and all that.
Great.
So May 30th of 2017 would be exactly one
week into the riots.
The protests that my classroom that
became relatively famous happened on May
23rd,
so one weekend and I was sitting in this
chair
and that feels like a lifetime ago
doesn't.
I mean it feels like it for me and I
think less has happened to me,
although it's been a pretty busy year
and a half.
The transformation of my life and
heather's life in that period has been
so dramatic that it's hard to even
relate.
I've never had so much happen in a year.
Yeah.
So.
Okay.
So for people that don't know anything
about the story,
and I suspect there's very few watching
this at the moment,
can you give me like the 92nd recap of
what happened?
So can that be done in 90 seconds?
Let's see.
It can be done with with carnage.
I must say I feared this question more
than any other because there's so much
detail in the story.
It can't be covered properly.
All right,
give,
give a cliff notes version that
basically,
and an explainer,
equity and inclusion movement got
started on my campus as it is on
virtually every campus and the new
president of Evergreen threw fuel on the
fire.
He used the division over that issue to
accomplish things he could not have
accomplished otherwise.
I tried to block his moves to dismantle
the excellent part of Evergreen's
teaching model,
which heather and I were using the full
effect.
And I became effectively enemy number
one of this equity and inclusion
movement.
They arranged a protest at my classroom,
very dramatic.
50 students showed up demanding my
resignation.
Not a single one of them was a student I
had ever encountered.
Um,
but in any case,
they made a terrible error.
They filmed their confrontation with me,
they uploaded it,
I now know to facebook somebody else in
the public,
uh,
picked those videos up and broadcast
them and the world watched me try to
reason with them and,
uh,
that set things in motion where
evergreen started using me as an excuse
for its problems.
It blamed me for what happened there for
the dropoff in enrollment for all sorts
of things.
And uh,
I started engaging with the public about
what was taking place at Evergreen about
issues of freedom of expression and free
inquiry on college campuses and
increasingly a evolutionary biology,
which,
you know,
people did not initially really
understand that.
That was the focus that I had,
not a freedom of speech issues.
Now increasingly that's what people want
to talk to me about,
although we're going to get to plenty of
that because I know that's what you're,
your real focus and passion is.
And it's sort of funny that now you've
been thrust into this.
Um,
but in effect you were protesting
putting racist policies on campus.
Is that fair to say?
Yes.
And this is one of the,
I think,
hardest lessons for people to learn.
People good people get the idea that you
can spot the right side by certain
heuristics and you know there's been a
historical fact of oppressed people
tending to be people of color,
et Cetera,
and so people have gotten lazy about
recognizing who's in the right.
If you follow a principal to its logical
conclusions.
In other words,
if you're against segregation,
for example,
as I am,
then when the segregationists are
telling white people to leave campus or
asking them to leave campus,
then you are committed to standing
against segregation.
And when you do stand against
segregation,
the world goes crazy because people who
are being lazy about recognizing which
side is defending the principle that
they,
they subscribe to a,
they fall out in the wrong place.
And so anyway,
yes it is your principles and adherence
to them that gets you in trouble.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you then show up in this studio a
week after this whole thing goes down.
It was your first public interview about
any of this.
What did you think at the time was going
to happen by talking about this publicly
or,
or what was your hope at least by
talking about this publicly?
Well,
you know,
initially my hope was to expose the
foolishness at evergreen and save the
college from its own worst instincts
because your audience may not care
terribly deeply about this,
but for a small number of people,
for 4,000
students at a time,
Evergreen was actually a wonderful
experiment in which it was possible for
people who hadn't had tremendous,
uh,
educational advantages before they got
to college to have an experience that
couldn't be reproduced anywhere else.
Evergreens model was so unique that if
you ended up in the right classrooms
with professors who really cared,
it was,
it was like no other place and,
and you were given incredible
a freedom as a professor to do what you
want it with these kids.
Right?
I believe that the position that heather
and I had was the freest academic
position in the country and maybe on
earth.
Well,
I mean really more freedom than a
tenured professor at Harvard has.
And that was,
let's be honest,
it was both a blessing and a curse if
you decided to use that freedom for
good,
if you decided to figure out how to
innovate structures that didn't exist
anywhere else,
you could do it and nobody could tell
you not to.
On the other hand,
if you decided to take the rest of your
career off and you know,
teach with one hand while you,
you know,
dealt with your hobbies,
you could also get away with murder.
And so that happened as well.
And you know,
there was attention every,
every good professor at evergreen
grumbles about the fact that there are a
large number of people who,
uh,
are holding positions there that they
don't really value.
And you know,
the,
the phrase that we,
that we typically used in private on the
faculty was that Evergreen paid in
freedom,
which meant that it didn't pay well.
It wasn't a good paying job,
but the ability to have a blank canvas
and decide how you were,
what you wanted to teach and in what
way,
and to innovate new mechanisms and take
students off campus for a week or two or
10,
that freedom was a very valuable
commodity that evergreen,
undervalued the whole time it should
have,
it should have leveled with people that
it was hiring and it should have said,
look,
this job is not going to make you
wealthy,
but it can make you very happy if you
have the temperament that really wants
to figure out what's possible.
So as this was unfolding and now you
went public and you also did Rogan and
you were on Tucker Carlson,
where you said,
I'm deeply progressive because suddenly
you were sort of getting crap from your
side,
so to speak,
and you were getting embraced by perhaps
a different side.
And I do want to get a little more into
that now because it shows what a sort of
crazy realignment politically we've had
these days.
Um,
were you shocked how deep it went?
So you went public,
you were,
you were giving the facts,
you were exposing sort of the corruption
and how it went all the way up to the
administration and all that.
I think from that first interview we
did,
I think you thought that there would be
a course correction in here,
or at least there was a chance for a
course correction and at least the way I
read the last year,
at no point was there even a slow down
or any reflection from the
administration and the rest of it,
they just went in on this.
I am completely shocked by the fact that
the world's recognition of just how
awful things were at evergreen did not
force an acknowledgement that something
was wrong.
So I would not have been surprised if
evergreen had backed off cynically if
they had privately said,
actually we were on the right track.
We were misportrayed and.
But we nonetheless have to acknowledge
what the world is saying to us.
The fact that that did not happen at all
still shocks me and I can't explain it
because you have a president who is
widely understood to be a.
is there a polite word for bond?
He's bonkers.
He is one of my favorite words like
bananas too,
but bonkers,
you know,
wackadoodle too young.
But in any case,
we have a president who was,
I mean,
look,
he's the mad king,
right?
He's the mad king and you've got a whole
bunch of people standing around.
I'm accepting his authority when in fact
he's an outsider,
is understanding of the college,
uh,
or his plans for the college are
completely inconsistent with the values
that the college was founded on.
Yeah.
And were they really accepting his
authority actually,
because there are moments in the chaos
of this that these videos are posted
where he can't even leave to go to the
bathroom.
And he was also a hostage in this,
in his own,
maybe his own,
like perverted a dream or something.
You know what I mean?
He was,
um,
both puppet and puppeteer.
Okay.
Um,
and so the thing is yes,
he is held hostage in those things,
but I believe he's a willing hostage in
the sense that he's trying to accomplish
something and you know,
look,
it tells the whole tail.
Once you say what we are doing is about
equity,
there is a whole swath of people that
cannot figure out how they would object
no matter what it is that you say next,
no matter what your plan is.
If you've said that it is for the
purpose of racial equity,
then a whole section of the population
will just fall in lockstep.
What is that?
What is that psychologically do you
think?
Oh,
I know because I think we're seeing this
everywhere now.
This is not just something that's
happening at universities anymore.
This is happening all over society.
I wish I could
say that it is an error in cognition
that people are seeing it incorrectly.
What I know for sure now as well as
anybody on earth is that the part of
people's minds that drives them in the
direction of silence,
of self editing,
of all of these things is actually
accurately perceiving a threat that it
cannot manage.
Now I'm not looking for sympathy.
I do not have my job anymore and I miss
it.
It was a great.
However,
I've landed on my feet.
I'm.
I wouldn't trade my position for any
other.
I like where I am.
However,
first of all,
there's not an infinite number of those
positions in the world,
so most people who are looking at some
sort of an equity and inclusion
juggernaut who are thinking,
should I stand up actually have to ask
themselves what happens if I do?
Do I have an economic plan B for my
family,
right?
Anybody who doesn't have an economic
plan,
B for their family and I have to say as
much as I would like evergreen to be a
place in which all the faculty had
enough skills that they could go do
something else.
If they have to,
they don't write.
They can't easily move to another
college because the way they teach at
Evergreen doesn't,
uh,
create a CV that will get you hired
elsewhere easily.
Um,
and so I think lots of people are
looking ahead and saying,
if I stand up and I say the right thing
now,
what,
what will,
what will become of me and the problem,
the place where I,
you know,
I have sympathy for anybody who sees
that and so I don't have a plan B,
I don't know what to do,
where I lose sympathy with them is when
they then having made that calculation
rationalize what they are saying and
they join,
not reluctantly,
but they become enthusiastic
allies of this movement in order to,
uh,
basically they sell the rest of us out.
Right?
And in a weird way,
they almost have to do that
psychologically to live with themselves.
Right?
I mean,
otherwise you realize that then you are
a sellout in the,
you know,
it,
it's harsh,
but it's true.
But what I'm so fat,
why?
The reason I'm so fascinated with this
is because as you know,
I've been on tour with Peterson for the
last couple months and I think this is
the number one question that we get
asked.
People want to speak up and they are
afraid of losing their jobs and,
and I think that's why your story
resonated with so many people because
people were looking at you and going,
well,
it's pretty freaking obvious.
This guy is not a racist.
He's not a hater.
He's a self identified left knee and a
progressive and all of these things.
And somehow he stood up to the monster
and I think the fact that you're still
here and you're,
you're,
you're not employed at the moment.
And now I do want to discuss that a
little bit too.
But the fact that you're still here,
you're alive.
You're still willing to talk about these
things.
I think that's the type of courage that
people are looking for at the moment.
Well,
you know,
I do.
So I have to say for a year now,
uh,
I have had these interactions,
you know,
a couple times a day somebody will come
up to me on the street and unless I'm in
Olympia,
it's always nice.
People have people,
even sons,
beard,
they're still coming up to.
Actually that has reduced it.
I think we're not quite sure there.
Is that who I think it is or is that
Eric or is it presented?
I don't know.
But you go buzz cut and then your
scottfree then.
Oh Man,
I'd be,
yeah,
I could go on the Lam.
They've never find me.
Um,
but
the thing is the,
it raises questions.
The stuff that people say to me about
what they see on the outside,
you know,
I get to compare that to what the
experience was on the inside.
And so I've done a lot of thinking about
what it is,
is,
you know,
is there some reason that,
that I stood up when others didn't.
And I think,
you know,
it comes down to something simple,
which,
you know,
I'll just,
I'll just put it out there.
I think people are rationalizing their
acceptance of this nonsense movement in
order to sleep and for some reason that
particular switch works the opposite way
for me.
If I heard myself rationalizing that I
would not be able to sleep.
So in order to sleep I had to stand up
and,
you know,
I'm lucky I have really good friends.
I have a wonderful brother who was
friends with you and that put us in
contact and uh,
I have something else to talk about.
You know,
evolutionary biology is fascinating to
people.
They don't know how to think about it
and they're,
you know,
just as my students where they're very
interested to hear what I have to say on
the subject.
So that means somehow,
even though I couldn't see it exactly on
May 23rd of 2017,
there was a path forward for me,
which,
you know,
it could come crashing down tomorrow,
but so far it looks good.
And I,
I,
I regret nothing.
Is there an evolutionary explanation to
that type of person that either can
sleep or cannot sleep?
Because you know,
people come up to all of us all the time
now and they say,
I wish I could speak up.
I don't want to lose my job.
My wife's pissed at me.
I mean all of these things.
And they're literally,
sometimes I'm talking to people one on
one and they're whispering.
I mean,
this,
this layer of fear is seriously real and
it is sitting on top of people.
So is there an evolutionary explanation
why at the moment it seemed like a very
small amount of people are doing it.
Absolutely.
And for me,
just quickly,
I would just say for me it's like,
I don't know if it's about sleeping,
I just,
I just feel like I'm doing what's right.
That's it.
It's actually not more,
uh,
you know,
it's not more a confusing or needs more
of an explanation
that that's just what I'm doing.
Um,
yeah.
There are two things to say on this
front.
One.
So I know we're going to talk more about
evolutionary theory later on,
but yeah,
there is a way in which evolutionary
theory stalled 30 years ago and I don't
believe that the explanation that you're
looking for is on the table in the way
that you know.
Any evolutionists that you asked would
say,
Oh yeah,
the explanation is over here,
but I do believe we can see what it is.
There are a lot of adaptations that do
not map well onto the individual.
If you look at the individual and you
say,
well,
why would the person behave this way?
It seems paradoxical sometimes if you
look at something larger than the
individual and it's not the group.
This is the thing.
We've been caught in this argument about
group selection since the sixties and
are actually even earlier,
but that's where it began to come to a
head.
If you look at the lineage that is to
say a population of people who are
related now talking about ancestral
ancestral population,
there are many characteristics that have
value for the lineage moving forward,
that are hard to understand from the
point of view of the individual and many
of the things that we have a really hard
time explaining,
including things like homosexuality and
religion.
Um,
many of these things are adaptations
that exist at that slightly higher
level.
And so what I would say is an individual
who can't sleep if they're not doing the
right thing or if they hear themselves
rationalizing that individual is not
well suited to certain jobs,
um,
but they're very well suited to other
jobs.
And the idea that a population has an
emergent nature and that,
you know,
a division of labor between,
I'm not telling you that not
rationalizing is the way we should all
be.
It may well be that we need certain
people who are very good at carefully
rationalizing certain things in order to
get jobs done.
I mean,
I would imagine if you are in the
military,
if you are in a position of command in
the military,
that there are certain things that you
have to rationalize in order to win the
war.
Now,
I'm not saying I don't like war.
I'm not saying that every word should be
one.
You know you shouldn't enter into a war
that isn't justified,
but once you've entered into it,
the goal is justified.
Maybe you have to rationalize certain
things.
You know,
you move troops over here in order to
protect something over there.
Well,
what are you doing to these people?
You may be sending them to their deaths
so you know,
even talking about it makes makes me
uncomfortable because it's not something
I would be good at,
but the point is when you look at the
population and the fact is the
populations that we have a live on earth
today are all winners,
right?
These are the winners.
Irrespective of how you got here,
irrespective of how oppressed your
population looks in relation to other.
Somehow you made it to the president.
You're a winner.
Those winning populations had many
characteristics within them and they
knew how to call upon these people and
you know,
sideline those people and then switch it
up at the point you arrive somewhere
else where different skills are
necessary.
So I'm in essence,
yeah,
I think there's a very simple
evolutionary explanation and some of us
have certain skills,
other people have other skills.
And the real trick is can you figure out
the switching mechanism that decides
what to call on?
At what moment?
That seems to be the key part of this,
right?
I mean that's it.
It's like some people are going to do
it.
Some people,
some people know they should do it and
won't do it.
Some people probably shouldn't do it and
do,
do it and everything in between.
Well,
you know,
you probably have this experience too,
but when I,
when people come up to me and they
talked to me,
there's just a couple of different
styles of conversation that unfold.
Um,
you know,
and there's lots of people who want to
apologize for what happened to me,
which I always find odd,
you know,
unless they were there in the room,
right?
Unless it was them,
but I'm guessing those people that have
never contacted me,
but,
you know,
some people want to apologize,
some people,
you know,
I want to thank me and some people,
there's this one thread which is I'm
facing something like this too.
Can you give me some advice?
And,
you know,
I always say the same sort of thing to
them and it throws them,
you know,
I always say,
look,
it's not safe.
You have to think very carefully about
what you're doing and don't kid yourself
about what you're signing up for and you
know,
you can,
you just watch in their eyes as they,
um,
grapple with the fact that they didn't
get what they wanted from me,
what they want it to be told.
They wanted somebody to egg them on and
say,
do it.
It's the right thing.
It'll work out.
And you tell them,
oh,
it may not work out.
And,
you know,
there's a moment of heartbreak,
but my hope is that the people who
should do it have to go through that
little heartbreak in order to get to the
other side.
And so among my various,
uh,
jobs at the moment is to show people the
abyss.
Just say,
look,
is this the abyss you want to jump?
If it is,
nobody can tell you that,
but you,
I certainly can't.
It would be irresponsible of me to tell
people to do something like what I did.
Because you could get,
you could get maimed.
Yeah.
And in a way it's sort of the shows that
I'm most proud of.
Here are the ones where I was able to
facilitate a little bit of that.
So it's sitting down with you.
It's sitting down with Lindsay Shepherd
who went through something very similar
in sitting down with James Damore,
these people who did not ask to be
heroes who even if I say the word hero,
I can see you're uncomfortable.
You know what I mean?
Like the people that didn't want this.
But somehow it got thrust upon them and
then and then they got there and then
hopefully I was able to amplify that a
little bit,
which then spreads that out to all sorts
of other people,
which is pretty cool.
So let's,
let's,
I know I don't want to do this for
obviously the entire interview.
So let's just catch up on a couple of
things.
We'll do a bit more.
So there's one,
one
thing that is,
and I believe there's a little caveat to
it.
If you do it and you'd do it for the
right reasons,
in other words could do it cynically.
You could stand up against one of these
things in order to see if you couldn't
get famous or something.
People will see through that,
right?
Especially the people who've gone ahead
down this road because they know
something about it.
But if you do it for the right reasons,
if you're really trying to advance the
ball to challenge a bad narrative,
the people who have gone through this
recognize it and you know,
it won't feed you,
but it is very reassuring to discover
other people who see a,
the corrupt narrative who understand
what happens when you challenge it.
Um,
so anyway,
if,
if you're hungry to meet other people
like that,
uh,
standing up,
you know,
you got to figure out what you're going
to do to feed yourself.
But it does put you in contact with lots
of people who,
uh,
are very worthwhile.
Yeah.
It's so interesting because again,
after being with Peterson,
it's like people will say to him,
you know,
I want to get a new job.
Should I just quit my job tomorrow?
And it's like you have to seriously
think about what your options are.
You may hate your job.
It doesn't mean you can leave tomorrow,
right?
You got to think about all of this
seriously.
And I think that that is the key here.
So I'm curious how much of this has
shifted what you think politically
because you do talk about politics now
and I know when I had you in there for
the first time,
I think I said to you,
we'll revisit this question because I
thought here's a guy that's,
that I come from a very similar
political places,
him as a progressive and all of these
things and now I see,
you know,
as you know,
I consider myself a classical liberal
and I,
and I love libertarian ideas.
Obviously we just did stand up together
last night and Bray California,
you and your brother joined me on stage
for the,
for the second half.
And it was mostly a conservative crowd.
There were some trump people,
there were some lefties and some
liberals,
but you know,
mostly conservatives and they,
they love you guys and yet you both
still identify as lefties and the whole
thing.
And I wonder now a year and a half
later,
are you shocked at that?
That you are now really liked by people
that perhaps you thought were your
ideology decal opponents and now you're
sort of on the outs with the people that
you used to be allies with.
Okay.
That's a good question.
I get one every episode.
I am
heartened and flabbergasted by what I
encounter on the center.
Right.
You know,
this is not the Republican party that I
remember from my youth.
This is a very different entity and I
think it has a lot of refugees who've
been driven out of other places and
they've grouped there because I don't
because because something over there is
making sense to them.
Well,
as you said to me the first time we met
Dave,
you have ptsd from political,
from the compressions.
Yeah.
And I must say we should,
we should return to this,
but I,
uh,
was very
heartened to hear you bring that up
during your episode with a,
with Ben Shapiro and Eric and Jordan.
You,
uh,
you went through a cool exercise which I
think deserves a place.
I'm with steel manning.
And your exercise I think was something
like where is someplace that you suspect
your own thinking might be incorrect and
you brought up political ptsd as a place
to pay attention to,
but let's just say I am shocked that,
uh,
the center right seems to be,
you know,
it has protective custody of liberty and
free speech and science of all things.
I mean,
how the heck did the center right ended
up end up having custody of these things
which are traditionally things that the
right is uneasy about and the left,
uh,
has,
has defended.
But nonetheless,
the people who value them are where they
are.
I think they do have something wrong.
You have your initial question was,
has this changed my political view?
And I think one of the everybody said it
would.
And I,
you know,
I,
I believe I am being honest with myself
when I say really hasn't changed my view
of what is true politically much if at
all.
I think because what I believe is true
isn't predicated on anything social.
Right?
In other words,
these are the conclusions that I reached
through game theory and evolutionary
thinking.
And observation of the political
landscape,
they're not things,
you know,
it wasn't that I went to a dinner party
and had a good time and fell in with
their political ideas.
So it's not,
you know,
the fact that I am not,
I'm welcomed in certain quadrants of the
left.
It doesn't change anything about what's
true at all.
Right.
It can't.
So I,
I understand that.
But at the same time,
I mean,
you can go to.
I've done public events with you that
are usually.
We're usually invited by libertarian
organizations.
We've done some Iran things together
and,
and a couple other things.
And I think everything that we've done
publicly and when you joined me for
standing up,
the crowds all basically seem to be on
the right as you're saying this sort of
new,
this new center,
right?
That maybe needs a better phrase than
that because center rights or it needs
something sexier than that per se.
Um,
but I mean,
have you been invited anywhere by
progressives to,
to tell your story or to get some
comradery or empathy or sympathy or
Kudos or anything other than Gfe?
Occasionally,
and only slightly,
I mean,
the,
the asymmetry is amazing and I must say
one of the most interesting things to me
about the early phase of this public
part of my life is that initially there
was just this overwhelming,
uh,
a message that came back at me.
You are a conservative or to
conservatism or something like that.
And welcome to the dark side I think is
what they usually do.
Say that.
And then at the point that a,
the phrase idw showed up on the
landscape.
Then there was this point about,
oh,
the idw is a right wing movement or
something like that.
And so there's a trajectory there.
There's something we track immediate
effects pretty well as people we can
observe them and detect them.
There's often a slower pattern that is
harder for us to see.
And so just by analogy,
I find this is true with healing,
physical healing.
If you do damage to your knee,
for example,
there's a one month healing trajectory,
but there's also a one year and a five
year trajectory and they're much harder
to spot.
Um,
so anyway,
the,
the interesting thing is the challenge
of you're on the right or now surely you
will be moving to the right,
you know,
that was just an overwhelming message
that came back.
Um,
but the ability to talk back to that
message and say,
actually no,
still on the left,
actually part of a left you don't even
remember exists.
And one of my fears is that all of the
stuff that the left was correct about is
not getting properly credited now.
So to the extent,
I don't know if people have seen this
hidden tribes,
a report that came out maybe a month ago
now that says that there's this vast
Osass,
80 percent in the middle do agree on,
you know,
the desirability of a fair society that
doesn't burden one population in order
to enrich one another.
And uh,
you know,
that we basically share
that basically it's only eight percent
actually that buy into this hyper
political correctness and the,
and the rest of it is a tiny fringe.
The authoritarian
left and it's a tiny fringe on the,
you know,
the white nationalist,
right?
And the rest of us in the middle,
you know,
we're not in perfect agreement,
we don't agree on the order of the
priorities,
but we do agree basically on what a good
society would function like and that a
lot of the gains,
I mean,
you know,
the ability to be gay and out and
function in society without that being a
tremendous obstacle that that's
something that,
you know,
the left deserves credit for a racial
equality,
you know,
equity is a different beast by virtue of
the new,
uh,
I hesitate to even call it that
definition because it's not a definition
in the standard sense,
but equality,
these are traditional left values and we
were right about.
And so the fact that these things are
now no longer controversial that belongs
in the discussion to the left has been
right about some stuff.
It's also been wrong about some stuff.
And the right has been right about some
stuff and it's been wrong about some
stuff.
And it is time for that conversation.
Absolutely.
And that's why I don't denigrate what it
was.
I am upset with what it is.
And perhaps guys like you and your
brother and Sam,
some people that still identify as left,
these will be able to do a reclamation
project that I just don't see anymore.
I see sort of more that this thing needs
to burn.
So out of the ashes of Phoenix can rise.
That's just maybe a little bit of a
tactical thing,
but let's just jump back to an
evolutionary explanation for some of
this.
So I asked you about why some people can
do this from an evolution,
evolutionary perspective,
why some people are able to step up and
some people aren't.
What about,
what's the evolutionary explanation for
why this,
let's say eight percent,
very loud,
but small group of people feel the need
to purge everyone.
Is there.
Is there an evolutionary because that
seems it would be almost counter to
evolution.
You'd want to have more commonalities
with people and bring in a big tent.
But what I see them consistently doing
is just getting rid of everybody who
dare you.
Talk back to the,
to the God.
Well,
you know,
I,
I wish I had known this was going to
come up because I would have looked it
up,
but there was a,
uh,
there was,
put me on the spot.
Say I'm a report that emerged,
maybe it was six or eight months ago
that I don't know.
I haven't looked into it and it's not my
area of specialty,
but,
uh,
it sounded right to me.
And what it said was that there is a
particular,
um,
there's a particular personality trait,
authoritarianism that isn't ideological.
It doesn't really care whether it's a,
you know,
defending fascism or communism,
what it wants to do,
his boss,
people around.
And that essentially what's confusing to
people is that at the moment these dyed
in the wool authoritarians are
concentrated over on the left and
they're saying stuff that sounds
nominally like leftist stuff,
but that,
you know,
we're the winds to shift.
And the authoritarians have the moment
to be over on the right.
They be there.
And so,
uh,
that,
that makes sense to me.
And what I would like people yourself
included to consider is that there is
almost no point in engaging those
people,
right?
This question of the importance of
liberty is settled,
right?
The 80 percent of us in the middle all
get
the fringe on the far left and the far
right are,
I don't want to say safe to ignore
because they can always rise up and
become important as the one on the left
is doing.
Um,
however,
that's not where the game is.
The game is all of the people who can't
figure out how to escape from the stigma
and all that is driving civilization.
So all of the people who are falling in
line with what's going on on the
authoritarian left,
those are the people to reach.
And what you raised about,
you know,
let's say the audience last night at the
comedy club and you know,
this is reliable.
This was the second one I with you.
It was exactly the same the first time.
The thing that is so heartening is,
you know,
I can come into a room and you're right,
that room last night must have been 95
percent right of center and first thing
you tell them is,
here's a,
uh,
a progressive.
I'm,
I tell them I'm a radical,
right?
Yeah.
It doesn't dampen their enthusiasm one
bit.
In fact,
it,
they're thrilled to discover that things
are not so bleak and that there is
somebody on the other side of this thing
who's still talking reasonably and can
hear them and can see them and doesn't
think that they're racist and out of
control.
And so anyway,
you know,
I know I take a lot of flack for
interacting with the right and I'm not
listening to that flag because it is the
best thing we can do is to engage and
uh,
you know,
when you spot the humanity of the people
on the other side,
then to the extent that we differ over
something,
we can talk about it.
All right,
well we could keep going down this
Pandora's box of,
of lunacy related to everything that
you've been through.
But let's do,
let's just catch it up to where we are
now and we can start looking at the
future a little bit.
So you and your wife had there who you
referenced.
Heather.
Hi.
Who's been on the show?
Uh,
who's a brilliant professor as well.
And,
and,
and has that,
that brave evolutionary tick that you
have to have you end up marrying a woman
that was going to have the same
evolutionary tickets.
You,
that's pretty good.
You really want to know the answer.
Yeah,
I'm heather and I,
we were not going out but we were
friends in high school and I don't know
that others will understand the phrase,
but the one that runs in my head is
somebody goes to high school with the
girl you should marry and it might be
you.
Right?
So anyway,
in my case,
you know,
I don't know how because you know,
I was,
I was a confused kid.
Like every other kid that age,
there was something about her that
seemed so very right.
And I have to say I was right about that
best decision I ever made.
Was she ever pissed at you during this
because you sort of thrust her in the
spotlight to,
and the fact is both of you left your
jobs,
you got a $500,000
settlement for two tenured positions,
which to some people that's $500,000.
I was like,
it sounds like a lot of money,
but,
but this is your life's work.
You and your wife,
you've since relocated your family and
your two kids.
Um,
so this is,
this is massive.
500 grand in the scheme of that is not a
lot,
but was she ever never
bothered or,
or hesitant by what you doing?
Because she didn't go public about this
until a bit after.
Um,
she was never pissed.
Not for a minute.
She and I were in complete agreement.
We saw the same thing unfolded
evergreen.
The,
uh,
the nature of our teaching at Evergreen
was kind of interesting in the sense we
had like a little undeclared graduate
program and evolutionary biology where
we couldn't award you a master's degree,
but if you were interested in
evolutionary biology and many people
didn't know they were,
but they would take my program and uh,
then I would sort of nudge them over
towards Harrisburg.
I'm.
So we had students bouncing back and
forth and we had a community of people
that were in our circle.
So the basic point is that creates a,
a,
an opportunity for every night at
dinner,
either an,
I would compare notes,
what we were seeing at the college and
all of these things talk about,
you know,
students,
what the students blind spot is,
what they do particularly well.
And as this unfolded,
heather and I saw the identical,
a picture or maybe the way to say it is
the picture of what was happening
emerged between us as we discussed it.
And she was,
let's put it this way.
What put me in the bullseye was the
emails that I wrote.
And the thing is,
I said in faculty meetings,
I never wrote an email that heather
didn't look at first and tell me it's
ready and frankly there were a lot of
emails that I didn't send and if I made
one error,
I believe I should have sent everyone
right,
because what they do is they leave a,
a historical record of what is taking
place.
So the descent was in retrospect,
very clear as you went back through the
emails.
Um,
but anyway,
yeah,
heather,
heather was in complete agreement the
whole time and I think,
uh,
the confrontation was less in keeping
with her personality traits than mine,
but in terms of her commitment and her
belief in what we were doing,
it was a team effort.
There's a lesson in marriage right
there.
And there's probably many lessons in
marriage.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
So let's just get to where you are now.
You guys have left Washington.
Neither one of you are teaching at the
moment.
You're trying to figure out what your
future is.
I assume the same with heather.
What is that like,
number one and number two?
I think a lot of people would be
surprised to know that schools have not
thrown offers at you.
I mean,
you,
you have a seriously great public
profile now you are respected by so many
people.
You have,
you have fans and not just students.
Now you have former students,
but you have fans that would love to
sign up for courses that you would be
teaching and all sorts of things where I
think most people would look at this on
their face and think,
wow,
what an asset this would.
This guy would be not only
intellectually but pr wise and all that.
That's not where we're at.
It's absolutely not.
And it,
uh,
it does say something and I'm,
I'm an outsider to whatever discussions
it is that result in nothing of that
sort coming our way,
but it is conspicuous.
Um,
so you asked what it's,
what it's like,
um,
you know,
I'm having a,
a,
a very unusual experience in life.
And you know,
my,
my life was great before any of this
happened.
It's great now.
Um,
the lack of security is frightening when
I stare at it,
you know,
heather and I have two kids and if we
didn't,
we would be in a different position.
We could take risks and we could afford
to go through,
you know,
years of austerity.
But as it is,
we have responsibilities and you know,
our kids didn't sign up for this.
Um,
so I mean they would have said,
are you saying they didn't get that
gene?
What are you telling me?
Oh no,
they're bored,
but it's our responsibility to protect
them.
And so,
you know,
the whole thing has been a
frightening from the point of view of
what it means for the future because
literally,
I don't know,
it seems like things are headed along a
path in which,
you know,
the settlement that you mentioned is a
tiny fraction of what we would have
earned over the rest of our careers.
And a huge amount of it was burned up
paying lawyers and uh,
taxes,
you know,
you get all that money in one chunk.
So we got about two years of buffer
money from that,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't like we got bought out.
We,
uh,
we could have in a state that had
punitive damages,
we likely could have won a,
something much more like 4 million bucks
for the amount of income that we would
have earned over the rest of our
careers.
How and why did you guys not go that
route?
Because I think a lot of people,
when they saw the number,
I remember when I saw the number,
I think I just saw an article or
something and I was like,
Whoa,
why so low?
Because Washington is one of 11 states
without punitive damages.
It's that sense.
Oh,
I thought you said that Washington
didn't have punitive damages.
Oh,
I just misheard you.
Okay.
So that,
that,
uh,
that caused us
to,
uh,
effectively cut our losses and decide
that it,
there was nothing to be done.
We did the best we could with evergreen
in cutting our ties with them at the
point that they made it clear.
I mean,
they,
they behaved atrociously in negotiations
for one thing.
They dragged their heels,
they wouldn't sit down with us until we
were already back on contract for the
next year,
fully assuming that we would be going
back into a classroom,
but what would it be like to walk onto a
campus that is,
you know,
paying a pr firm to demonize you.
Right.
What would that be like?
And we would have done it,
but they,
uh,
they insulted us in negotiations.
They offered us panic buttons.
Right.
As if.
So panic buttons in the room literally.
Yeah.
Like,
as if the problem was that we were
panicking,
you know,
rather than that they had,
they could've at least they offered you
a counter baseball bat.
Wouldn't that have been nice?
Right.
Something,
um,
but they didn't to end,
you know,
hobbling the police.
The whole thing was a fiasco.
So we cut our losses.
We've,
we've moved,
he moved to Portland,
which is wonderful.
I know that's
in some ways,
not interpretation,
but it is a marvelous place.
You went to the only more progressive
place.
Uh,
it does seem that we have here a glutton
for punishment onto that
belly of the beast.
But I,
you know,
the,
the beauty of Portland,
you know,
there's a beauty and there's a tragedy
there is this a equity and inclusion
thing and it seems to go up to the
mayor's office who happens to also
frighteningly and a parallel to
evergreen be the police commissioner so
he can stand down the police and,
and has done so in some sort of
from that video from a couple of weeks
ago with antifa basically running
traffic in the middle of Portland.
I mean,
it's,
it's unfathomable that that's happening
in the streets of the United States
city.
Right,
right.
It is.
They are flirting with the same.
I mean,
it is the same story as evergreen
except,
um,
this is a major American city,
you know,
to have a college,
a play games with literal anarchy is
dangerous enough to have a city doing
it.
Uh,
I shutter to them.
Thank you.
Didn't want to think about Texas.
I really on this tour.
I got to tell you to San Antonio,
I think you'd have a field day over
there.
Well,
but here's the thing,
other part of liberalism is also true.
Important.
So I never encounter a,
the antifa madness and the mayor and his
confusion,
you know,
it's like the mayor of your town,
you never,
never run into it.
What I do run into is a clean,
a functional city.
People as far as I can tell,
are very decent to each other.
Um,
you know,
to make provisions for cyclists to
commute around the place.
So I think in some sense Portland is,
it shows exactly the conflict between
the left better instincts in its worst
instincts.
And uh,
I hope that it will come around to the
kind of enlightened progressivism that
used to exist rather than the naive
progressivism that seems to have taken
over.
All right,
let's shift all together.
Let's do it.
Let's talk about the step.
You really know.
How about that.
Okay.
Biology,
evolutionary biology.
I thought this would be an interesting
place to start.
You just recently did a talk with
Richard Dawkins just in the last couple
of weeks.
Uh,
as I understand the video of it should
be up online somewhat soon.
It will be up within a couple of weeks.
Okay.
So hopefully people will be able to
actually watch this conversation.
I'm very quickly,
this event was put together by
Pangbourne philosophy.
There's been a little tumbled around
that and I know you just wanted to
quickly address what's going on there.
So pangbourne philosophy is obviously
imploded and that has
left people speculating about what
happened and why some of us like myself
continued to participate with Pangbourne
just very quickly for people that have
no idea.
They were putting together a lot of the
public events that included a,
well the one that you moderated with
Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris in
Vancouver.
Also the one that Douglas Murray
moderated,
which I think was that in the UK or was
that Australia is one in Dublin and one
in London.
Um,
and then a series of other events like
the one that you did with Dawkins and
this this day of reflection that was
supposed to happen on November 17th that
we all pulled out of which now I think
you can take it from there.
Sure.
So,
um,
let me just say that I know that there
is a lot of speculation about what took
place.
Why people pulled out of the New York
event,
why some of us like myself stayed in and
I was in at the point that it was
canceled a couple of days ago and I do
hope people will recognize that there
was a predicament for those of us like,
uh,
like myself and like Eric who were
looking at the,
uh,
the Pangbourne situation and trying to
figure out what to do,
which was at the point that Pangbourne
canceled the Auckland event,
something new emerged.
So other events had been canceled,
but there had always been refunds for
people who had bought tickets at the
point he canceled the Oakland event.
There was a lack of refund money,
which called our attention to the fact
that something was off money that should
have been kept separately for that
event.
So that if it was canceled,
it could've all been refunded somehow
wasn't with.
We didn't know.
And,
and to be clear,
you guys,
and I think not just,
you guys hadn't been paid for some
previous things too.
So it wasn't just about the people that
were buying the tickets.
Just,
Oh,
it wasn't Auckland,
it was Sydney,
Sydney is where speakers,
as far as I know,
that's where speakers didn't get paid
for the first time and I'm certainly one
of the people who didn't get paid and
still haven't been.
Anyway.
Yeah.
And also as a sidebar,
that's.
So that is why I pulled out of the day
of reflection thing in New York.
I was supposed to host the whole day,
but then when I realized that people
hadn't been paid for previous things and
I had heard through the grapevine that
there was some shady stuff going on and
I just said,
you know what,
let me just not get involved in this
mess in that.
Which makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
So I think what I did also makes perfect
sense,
uh,
which is,
I looked at the situation and I said,
well,
you've got people who haven't been
refunded their money for Auckland.
You've got speakers from Sydney who
haven't been paid and if the New York
event comes apart,
then it's going to compound that.
It's going to create new,
a ticket holders who haven't been paid.
Um,
and so my thought was let's have an
event that gives people what they paid
for so that we don't make the damage
worse and I certainly didn't sign up for
anything new after the Oakland event was
canceled and there was a failure to
repay patrons.
But my thought was from the point of
view of protecting the fan base from
whatever was going on behind the scenes
at Pangbourne,
the better part of valor was to make the
event happen and be successful rather
than create another auckland situation.
So in any case that,
you know,
and I should also point out that up
until so Pangbourne gave us a,
a little bit of warning just a couple of
days before he canceled it.
He said he was about to cancel it.
And Eric and I tried to save it.
In fact,
Eric,
who had pulled out of the event quietly
so as not to cripple it,
uh,
and he and I got on the phone with
Travis and we tried to get travis to
agree to hold the event and to let us
rescue that.
We offered to work for free and we would
have liked to have held the event so
that it wouldn't cause further harm to
people and I don't know why Travis
refused,
but he did.
So anyway,
it got canceled and I,
uh,
I just,
I do want people to understand that it
was not that anybody was unaware that
something was going on.
The question was what's best for the fan
base,
the movement to the extent that there is
a movement,
is it better to have another event
canceled and have more harm?
I didn't think so.
Yeah.
And I know this is all a little insider
baseball for people,
so I know you just want it to get that
out.
So I'm glad that it is a few of us.
Also,
we had discussed possibly doing a free
thing and who knows,
maybe there will be something in the
future if people end up getting stiffed
on ticket prices because obviously we
want people to get something and if we
can all figure it out,
we will.
Okay.
So that being said,
you did do an event with Richard Dawkins
as we said,
the video should be up soon enough.
Chicago,
what should we expect from this?
And,
uh,
I think on its face,
I think a lot of people would say,
wait a minute.
Well,
we've got Weinstein and Dawkins,
these guys should agree on everything
she didn't they.
Well,
this goes back to the question of what
happened to evolutionary biology 30
years ago and um,
darkens and I do agree on a tremendous
amount,
but the place at which we start
disagreeing I think is a branching point
where you have the way evolutionary
theory went 30 years ago and the way it
should have gone,
and you know,
that's not an indictment in and of
itself.
Fields take wrong turns all the time.
But what should happen is you should
detect that you're on the wrong path
because suddenly progress ceases.
And that didn't happen.
So,
so what actually happened 30 years ago
that got us?
Ironically,
I would argue that the last piece of
progress that we all really agree now,
there's been lots of empirical work,
but the last piece of theoretical
progress actually involves a Dawkins'
selfish gene,
which is essentially encapsulates a
synthesis that does lots of things,
including brings a proper theory of
cultural evolution online.
Which cultural evolution is a non issue
for almost all creatures.
But for birds and mammals,
it's a big deal.
And for human beings it is the big deal.
So to the extent that we did not have a
way of discussing cultural evolution
prior to the selfish gene doctrines,
introduction of the concept of memes
which have now been trivialized by,
you know,
people putting funny captions on
pictures,
but the concept of,
I think you could argue they've become
the most relevant way of communication
in a bizarre way this.
But they'd be.
They've become,
you know,
little tidbits become little bites and
the fact is almost everything about
human beings that is interesting and
special,
at least touches cultural evolution if
not is entirely housed there.
So in order to understand ourselves,
we have to get this cultural revolution
things straight and document set us,
I believe,
on the right path.
Chapter Eleven,
he introduces the word meme,
he introduces the concept,
he sets us in motion,
but he makes an error in that chapter.
No big deal.
We all make errors,
but it hasn't been corrected in 30
years.
And so so.
So what does that error?
The error is in a,
a misportrayed will of the relationship
between culture and its evolutionary
units and genes and the way that they
evolve.
So what Dawkins says and that chapter is
that means the units of cultural
evolution exists in a new primeval soup,
right?
He says,
this is a new kind of evolution.
It begins at the point that culture
begins to happen and it is independent
of the genes that cannot be the case
cannot be the case because the only
reason that you are able to pick up
units of cultural evolution is because
you have a brain that your genes created
which is hospitable to those things.
Which means that to the extent that your
a culture starts wasting the time.
And the energy and the resources of your
genes,
the genes are in a perfect position to
shut it down.
Right?
So my point to Dawkins on stage in
Chicago was,
that can't be right,
and if you make an adjustment to the
theory that you darkens presented in
1976,
if you adjust it correctly,
you discover that,
um,
many things that are paradoxical about
cultural evolution are no longer
paradoxical and many things about human
beings are suddenly tractable.
So can you give me an example of that?
I can give you the ultimate example.
I will accept that.
And so the ultimate example has to do
with a religion and things that function
like it.
So if you think about,
um,
you know,
this is the antithesis of some little
picture with a caption on it,
right?
You Imagine Catholicism,
for example,
Catholicism is a set of beliefs that has
profound implications on the way that
believers deploy their efforts,
their resources to things that they
elevate,
the things that they,
uh,
issue all of that.
So the question is why?
Right?
So dawkins and I would agree there is no
supernatural explanation necessary to,
uh,
interpret what is taking place on earth
or anywhere else in the universe.
You don't need a supernatural
explanation if you were trying to
explain phenomena.
So why is it that people who hold a
belief that supernatural forces are at
the heart of a human affairs?
Why are those people so successful?
Historically?
That's the question.
And Dawkins,
and I disagree with it,
I would disagree over it,
uh,
because a,
he has this view of what cultural
evolution is that it's independent of
genes.
I say it is actually much more flexible
than jeans,
but it is subordinate to the will of the
genes.
Um,
and he also does not subscribe.
Actually,
he came around a bit on this on stage I
thought,
um,
but he also does not subscribe to a,
uh,
a lineage level interpretation of
selection.
He is a traditional Ken selectionist who
believes effectively that the
individual,
that the gene and the individual are the
places that we must interpret a
evolution.
And if you do that,
then lots of things are paradoxical,
hard to explain.
Maybe intractable,
if you accept that lineages evolve,
um,
that adaptation can apply to the
lineage,
then you can begin to understand
phenomena like a religious traditions as
adaptive properties of a population.
And uh,
there is tremendous progress to be made.
So what happened on stage with Dawkins
was at dinner prior to the event,
we more or less agreed that I would lead
the discussion because I had a sense of
where we disagreed and he would react to
it and I put together a list of points
on which I was certain that we agreed
points on,
which I was pretty sure we disagreed and
points on which I wasn't sure which way
to call it,
which we didn't get to.
But anyway,
I started out by pointing out the vast
agreement between the two of us and
asked them about each one and more or
less I had been right about where we
agreed.
And then I started to go through the
list of places that we disagree.
And I thought it was a fascinating
conversation.
It was definitely a closer to the
conversation I hoped we would have won.
I feared we might have,
um,
there was a lot of progress.
Could you,
could you sense which way,
not that this matters in the grand
scheme of things,
but at,
at some level it does,
which way the audience was going,
not that it,
not that it is about who gets more
cheers or anything,
but what I do find fascinating about
these things and although I didn't
attend any of the live events with Sam
and Jordan,
um,
you know,
I've watched some of them and just sort
of noting a little bit of crowd applause
and jeers and pauses and things I think
gives you some extra taste that may be
for you guys on stage.
You can't quite quantify.
Well,
I mean,
first of all,
I'm a believer in that and it was one of
the most important tools that I used to
use in the classroom.
You know,
figuring out what people heard,
how it landed,
what they don't yet have.
So anyway,
I'm very cognizant of what people are
hearing and I was listening carefully to
the audience and um,
you know,
the thing was set in motion,
as another new atheist event.
And so in some sense I was,
I was battling uphill because my basic
point was new atheism is,
is a Culdesac,
it's,
it's a problem in and of itself.
It's a problem because at the end,
at the end of it,
there isn't enough.
Is that like the most simplistic way
that I could present it?
No.
I mean,
let me just put it in stark terms.
Atheism is defensible,
but new atheism is wrong and new atheism
is wrong because it portrays religious
belief as a defect of mine rather than
an adaptation and non literal
adaptation.
And so in a room full of people who,
you know,
Dawkins is a very famous person,
most people presumably showed up to hear
a Dawkins.
Almost all of those people have at least
deep sympathies with the ideas of new
atheism.
And so somebody setting out to say
actually new atheism is an incorrect
instantiation of atheism because it is
effectively ideological and it accuses
people who have religious faith of being
mentally defective.
And in fact Dawkins and I tangled over
this,
you know,
I said,
look,
you're,
you've called religion a mind virus.
That's an incorrect interpretation.
And at first he said,
well,
I don't really mean anything deep by
virus.
He said it's,
you know,
you could argue that every gene in the
genome is like a virus,
right?
And I said,
well,
but what people hear when you say that
is that,
that they're mentally ill for believing
this.
And he said,
well,
they are mentally ill,
right?
And so,
you know,
you could see the division in his own
thinking,
right?
Because they're at that point,
he's then saying both things at the same
time saying both things.
And I,
you,
I understand his position about you
could interpret each gene as
independent,
you know,
I could defend that position too,
but in order for there to be an
honorable atheism,
we have to own up to what all that
religious belief was about.
And then,
I mean,
and this is the place that I get into an
easier pickle,
a pickle with Peterson as well,
is the question of if we acknowledge
that religious belief is adaptive,
then all of the things that are true of
adaptive phenomena kick in and the most
important one is that adaptive phenomena
are not timeless.
They are adaptive relative to a
historical time and place.
And it may be a very long standing time
and place.
But the point is there is nothing.
It is purely magical thinking to imagine
that religious traditions that are
thousands of years old are the core of
the toolkit for moving forward.
Our,
our existence in 2018 is so novel that
if there's one thing we can be sure of,
it's that are adaptive nature is a poor
match for it.
So then can anything be truly timeless?
Is that the right question?
Well,
yeah,
but the way you do it is this,
the longer standing,
some truth of some kind is the closer it
gets to being timeless.
In other words,
if we look at things that are,
um,
very evolutionarily longstanding,
well those things have persisted through
environments that were very different
from each other.
So what that means is that thread still
functions irrespective to an extent of
the context.
The longer it lasts,
the more likely it is to speak to truths
that continue to be relevant,
but the,
the bitter pill for modern people with
respect to understanding the degree to
which evolution is the key to seeing
ourselves properly is that we live in
circumstances that are more novel than
almost any creature has ever faced.
Now,
you know,
a creature can fished and flop into a
boat and it's suddenly a novel
circumstances and it's dead within
minutes.
Right?
Don't tell that to the dinosaurs in the
media was going well there.
Yeah,
there you go.
That was so novel that you know,
I mean dinosaurs didn't survive that one
group.
The birds are still with us and they're
doing great,
but we are creatures living in
circumstances that are not only novel at
an unprecedented level,
but are changing so rapidly that even to
the extent that we can figure out what
to do,
the world changes out from under us.
We have to stop that right?
That is going to kill us.
That if you want to know what the
greatest existential threat to humanity
is,
it is the rate of change that we have
set in motion which makes it impossible
for us to adapt fast enough to it.
It has to be slowed down to a point that
we can catch up.
Is that impossible though,
because we already have that power
because I'm with you on this.
Just from my limited knowledge of this,
just from what I do,
you know from doing these shows and that
people can watch more.
You know the amount of information that
you can intake on a given day.
The amount of things that you can share.
You can speed things up and listened to
them two times as fast.
You can clip everything and that we can
take all of this information.
Things can be live streamed,
all of this,
Bang,
Bang.
It's happening faster.
We're learning more.
We know there's a great
thirst for this.
Um,
but can it be slowed down?
I mean,
what,
what force could slow down progress
really wisdom.
Um,
and that,
that's the,
that's the problem is that.
Thank you.
We are children in this landscape and
children grow up,
right?
I mean,
the key to raising children properly is
to,
is to back off the things that protect
them enough that they actually get
burned without being burned so severely
that they're crippled.
In other words,
you have to experience the places that
your notions are naive in order to
become less night.
We are now in a situation in which we
are behaving in a childlike fashion in,
you know,
in a very,
in a foundry or something like that.
Right?
We're like children running around in
the foundry.
There's molten metal that we need to
figure out how to recognize it,
how not to.
We were just pressing every button.
Buttons are cool.
Our.
Yeah,
we got to stop doing that.
I don't think,
you know,
if I'm to be candid about it,
I don't think we are in an unrecoverable
situation.
I can see the path forward and it's all
still plausible as far as I know,
but I'm worried that we won't get there
and the reason we won't get there is
that there are lots of things that have
been true that just aren't true anymore.
In other words,
the people who are in love with,
you know,
a limitless market in which you can do
anything that you can manage and it's
all cool.
And then at the point we find out that
it isn't cool.
We might have to take some action,
but in the meantime,
you know,
you're,
you're free to explore.
I'm very sympathetic to this view,
as you know.
Well,
I would be sympathetic to this view if I
didn't recognize that there was a
problem in which,
for example,
if you look at the way our economic
system is hooked up to our political
system,
there is a problem where anytime you set
a new force in motion in the market,
if that force pays at a high rate in the
short term,
but it costs at a high rate in the
longterm,
by the time you get around to
discovering the costs in the long term,
it has found its way into the political
system so that it cannot be reversed.
And you can't have a system in which you
can't reverse them.
So this,
the simplest way to frame this would be
some sort of crony capitalism kind of
thing,
right?
Well,
you know,
we're not,
we're not truly free market because
we've politicized competition basically.
Well,
you know,
I tried to look at everything,
um,
through an evolutionary lens.
And to me,
politics and economics are just one more
landscape.
And they're interesting because it's
humans and humans are especially capable
in this regard.
But the,
um,
the natural tendency for a creature that
has found its way into a niche is to
protect its access to that niche.
And the way creatures do that is they
freeze other creatures out.
So there is this natural pattern.
I mean,
I can't not see it now that I now that I
understood that it exists.
There's this natural pattern where the
upstarts who succeed,
the stories that we know we don't know
about the upstarts that failed mostly,
but you have startups that succeed end
up tremendously powerful.
And then they go through this process in
which they become hostile to upstart
newness and they become hostile to
upstart and us for the most natural of
reasons which is that their wellbeing
depends on shutting down the process
through which they became successful.
So this could be like facebook buying
all their competitors and things of that
nature.
It's the,
let's put it this way,
there are obvious versions and then
there are innumerable versions that are
cryptic and we were never going to
understand the whole landscape of ways
in which those who have reached this
level of power that you and I will only
dream about,
that they will then shut down the access
to others.
It's like there's a,
I don't even want to call it a
conspiracy because it doesn't have to
have any consciousness to it at all,
but there is a tendency for,
um,
for those who have succeeded to shut
down the,
the mechanism through which they see.
I mean,
you can see this with a people
frequently remarking on the fact that
immigrants are often not that wildly
enthusiastic about further immigration.
Why is that?
For obvious reasons,
you know,
you're talking about do people who've
just entered at the bottom of the
economic ladder want more competition?
Well,
they're actually,
and there's a tension between what
people should want,
but you shouldn't imagine that there's
some immigrant ness that necessarily has
you favorable to anybody else who has
that label.
Does this also sort of explain a little
bit of what's happening in the tech
world right now in terms of it seems
that these companies,
twitter,
facebook,
youtube,
are potentially at least using
algorithms against their own audience,
a shadow banning people.
I mean that they are basically now
turning against their own people because
of their,
whatever they perceive to be their own,
uh,
protection or longterm health.
Even though I would argue in most cases,
that's not really what's going to
happen.
Oh,
without question.
This is what's going on and let's put it
this way.
If you're at the top,
if you're in that strata,
you have a lot to lose through anything
you can't predict.
And so there is a way in which we expect
the upstart who got there through some
sort of radical transformation to be
favorable to route a radical
transformation.
But the way we should understand it is
that once you've gotten there,
radical transformation becomes
threatening and you start to
conservatizing evolutionary force and
you know,
we can look at what twitter is playing
with these days with the potentially
eliminating like some follower counts.
You know,
at a breathtaking act of paternalism,
you know,
at best and are doing it for us,
for us,
right?
Because we shouldn't be so concerned
about who's paying attention.
But really the truth is,
as much as we all recognize that there's
a problem with,
you know,
tweeting to get trivial likes,
on the other hand,
understanding what your audience hears,
what they find favorable,
what doesn't ring true to them is the
way you learn,
it's the way you steer.
And so effectively twitter is playing
with blinding us so that we can say
whatever we want into the void,
but we have no idea how it,
there's no ping back to you basically.
And so,
you know,
I mean,
I don't need to tell you,
you're a comic,
you're standing in front of the room and
you get
a lot better when they laugh.
It's better,
it's better when they laugh.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Um,
what should we be thinking?
You know what?
Before I get to that.
So as you know,
I was just in a,
in Europe and I did a bunch of the
Scandinavian and Nordic countries and
Sweden was a particularly interesting
case because I know that our fifth most
viewed country for this show is Sweden,
which is sort of fascinating considering
how tiny Sweden is.
Uh,
so I,
I sort of circled that we did two shows
in Sweden.
I kind of circled them on the calendar
because I was like,
something's going on in Sweden.
I want to figure out what it is now.
I thought if you would have asked me
before I did the show that first night,
I thought it was gonna have a lot to do
with immigration.
What I realized,
although there were a lot of questions
about immigration at the end,
uh,
it had much more to do with gender and
what is happening to their highly
egalitarian society that have done most
of the things related to gender and true
equality correctly for many,
many years.
And all of our friends on the left
always point to Sweden and Norway and
Finland.
These countries that I was just at as
the examples of their perfect societies
and they're really struggling with
certain things that you know,
that the government is forcing them to
have genderless kindergartens and that
the,
the emasculation of men and the removal
of the father and that they have
supposedly Europe's first feminist
government and all of these.
So I thought as long as I have you here
and since gender seems to be such an
endlessly a provocative and also
misunderstood topic,
um,
what should we do on gender right now?
Yeah.
Um,
well beyond you go to Sweden and
figuring out what's going on here
because something.
Well,
what it struck me as is that they've
done everything right in effect in terms
of egalitarianism and they've done it
for,
for decades now.
They've done it right.
And when they got to the end,
which is now,
and they got to the current day,
they realized that despite all of this
equality,
men and women are still different.
That women still care more about people
and men still care more about things.
So even though they've been given the
exact same opportunity,
women are still becoming nurses and men
are still becoming engineers and it's
like the social justice warriors or
whatever you want to call that crew,
they still don't like the results of
true equality.
So I think that's why Sweden's in such a
weird place,
the average person's like,
what?
We've done it right when we did it
right.
Everyone's equal,
you can do whatever we want,
but then the result isn't being allowed
to be accepted.
Does that,
does that make some sense?
Oh,
it makes perfect sense.
I think
the,
uh,
the naive left finds the failure of its
hypothesis absolutely galling.
And so they're effectively trying to
erase that failure by hard coding the
solution into government.
So I think that's exactly what's
happening happening
in Sweden right now.
And it's tragic and with respect to sex
and gender,
it is so needless,
right?
The fact is the truth of sex and gender
is,
there are parts of it we don't fully
understand yet,
but in general,
actually we do.
We pretty much understand how we got
here.
And the truth is it is asymmetrical.
It is a complimentary,
the truth of male and female is a
complimentary truth.
It may be largely irrelevant in the
present.
In other words,
technology has eliminated most of the
basis on which the division of labor
between men and women initially evolved,
so I think we have actually an
opportunity here to become,
to behave in an enlightened fashion that
the the easiest place to solve this
problem is sex and gender.
What we should do is pretty clear and it
is not hard to ground and evolutionary
theory because unlike other places like
a race for example,
we do know what to think with respect to
sex and gender and the.
The basic outline is this.
Men and women are different for
historical reasons.
The basis for that difference and the
utility of that difference has largely
been neutralized by the modern world.
We don't need to retain those
distinctions,
but some of those distinctions are built
in at a deeper level than others.
So meaning you could potentially be a
stay at home dad and that could be
perfectly fine,
but that probably for evolutionary
reasons is not going to be the thing
that usually happens,
right?
But here's my point.
We can democratize access to almost
everything with respect to sex and
gender.
There are very few places where we
actually need to have,
um,
some asymmetry in access,
but probably,
you know,
the firefighter who comes into the
burning building through the roof to
pull you out when you're panicking and
you don't know what to do because you've
never been in a fire before.
Um,
on average,
that should probably be a guy.
They're just better built for it.
If there's a woman who is well enough
able to do it,
should you be picky about the
firefighter who plucks you out of the
burning building?
Absolutely not.
I mean,
I personally am thrilled to see it every
time it runs against the narrative that
we expect.
Right?
You know,
I,
uh,
I'm very fond of Stacey Brown,
the,
the police chief at Evergreen who was
driven out along with heather and me.
I thought it was great that she was
female and that she was a,
an excellent cop.
So I'm,
I'm up for the narrative being broken
by,
uh,
by reality as often as possible,
but you democratize the access,
but you don't force people to do what
they otherwise would for one thing,
you wouldn't even want to force it
because for every job that you would,
you know,
force women into it some higher rate,
let's say engineering jobs because it
sounds like a good thing to do.
There's some awful job that men are
disproportionately represented in that
you would also have to force them into
to be fair.
So you democratize the access.
You recognize that the division of Labor
that we have,
that we have inherited is largely
outdated.
Um,
but you don't a override people's,
uh,
show me,
you know,
if,
if women,
if you democratize access to engineering
perfectly and women go into it at equal
rates,
great.
If they don't,
that's cool too.
Um,
so in any case,
it's,
it's a question of allowing liberty to
decide where people go after you've done
away with not barrier.
Well,
it's so interesting because I think then
you hit it right on the head that,
well,
Sweden's now politicizing it.
They're making a point of making this
political because they will not accept
the science of what they've done
correctly.
And I think that that is what is,
what is lead this sort of average person
there to go this,
this is just not right.
So it's,
I don't know what the way out is and I
sense that most of the people there
didn't know at the way I was.
Well,
I mean the way out really is to
recognize that the,
the ire of the authoritarian left on
this point is actually indicative of the
whole problem.
In other words,
because sex and gender is more or less
clear,
the desire to erase it,
irrespective of the collateral damage is
an indicator of just how wrong this path
is.
So,
you know,
I find this all the time where people
have,
if you're not focused on biology and
you're focused on the world that you
find in your galled by,
uh,
by inequality,
then you think,
well,
let's just solve the inequality.
Which is hard code the solution,
but then you hard code the solution and
it says men and women of the same to the
extent that there's any difference in
what they choose to do,
that's the result of a either cryptic
barriers or internalized misogyny or
whatever,
and then the problem is you're now
interfering with my biology class.
You're now telling me that we that the
received wisdom is that men and women
are the same thing.
When I know damn well that can't be
right,
so you don't want to build a solution
that forces you to confront your
biologists,
physicists,
your statisticians,
right?
You want all of these stories to the
extent that they're true,
have to reconcile all true stories,
records to the extent that you've got a
naive notion over here and you want to
just write it in because it seems very
important to you and you're willing to
tolerate all of the cascading effects
elsewhere.
You don't belong in a position of power.
Unfortunately though,
a lot of those people are in a position
to power and I think we're seeing more
of them get into positions of power and
I think it's also now having a counter
effect in Europe,
which is why we're seeing the rise of
more far right parties because people
are just like,
screw this,
this is so wrong.
I'm going to take my chances over here.
People who inherently are not say far
right or certainly not racist,
are now playing with people that perhaps
they wouldn't have played with before
because they're so sick of this.
And I.
and I'm worried where that leads us.
Oh,
I think,
I think this is exact,
and I've,
I've heard you say this,
is that you were afraid that the,
the lunacy over on the authoritarian
left is actually going to collapse.
It's going to leave people who otherwise
wouldn't play ball with the far right.
Yeah.
Over there.
Um,
and not because they're racist.
That's the key to this.
It's not that they'll suddenly become
wake up and be racist or hate women or
hate gays,
but it will be such a disgust of,
of reality.
And,
and a,
and a rejection of what's provable,
that they'll be like,
at least there's something over here.
I mean,
it's,
it's an awful bargain,
but I think it is.
I think,
I just think it is.
I see this,
uh,
frequently where people,
you know,
because they detect that there's
something wrong with communism and
socialism are often driven,
right pretty far into the let's not
regulate anything camp and the answer is
actually have to regulate stuff just out
of a desire to continue as a species.
So,
you know,
I don't want to see people driven
because there's something wrong over
here.
I don't want people to be driven into,
into a reactionary position that is not
justified.
The thing on sex and gender though is
maybe this is the key question.
Every reasonable person who just simply
observes the world knows that men and
women are not the same thing.
They know that,
uh,
those differences have an implication
for the way we view all sorts of things
like mating and dating,
what careers we want to have,
how we view risk.
And all of these things for historical
reasons.
All reasonable people can infer that
from their own observations of the
world.
You are now confronted with people who
insist that you not acknowledge what you
can see.
Those people are crazy,
right?
They're dangerously out of control.
They're dangerously out of control on
other topics where it's harder to know
what's true,
but you wouldn't want people who were so
naive as to argue that men and women are
effectively identical,
but for depression,
in charge of any policy,
you don't want them in charge of
economic policy,
in charge of,
uh,
you know,
a prisons,
anything.
Um,
so having seen just how far their
confusion goes,
can we all agree to shut them out of the
discussion about how power is to be
wielded and the rest of us can have a
discussion about what our values are,
what we think we know,
what we don't yet know,
and what its implications are.
That that's the place we should go.
That seems like an effective ending
here.
Unless you want to throw in one more.
Did we not hit something that's been
rattling around in your brain?
Actually,
he's a know I covered a lot of territory
here.
Yeah.
All right,
well it's always a pleasure sitting down
India and you joined me last night for
standup in Bray California.
This'll be up already,
but you're joining me tonight in Oxnard.
I'm turning you into a standup comic,
which is a biologist.
Worst nightmare.
I don't know.
It's a,
it's not quite the,
uh,
the thing where you're,
the lead singer of your favorite band
has laryngitis state,
but it's about as close as I could hope
to go.
Yeah.
All right.
Well we're going to do this.
I will do.
Well,
we did it about a year ago after the
original one,
but we'll do this more than once a year
because you're,
you're right in the center of all the
things that I think are,
are right at the moment and for more on
Brett,
follow him on twitter as long as they
can track how many followers he has at
Bret Weinstein.